a good night's rest is a big part of
your overall health Sleep Experts
recommend getting seven to eight hours
of sleep every night which can be
difficult for a lot of people for a host
of reasons Dr Trent Knutson with
Intermountain Healthcare the sponsors of
this segment joins us with more
information on how you can get a good
night's rest doc thanks for joining us
glad to be here why is sleep so
important well we all know how well our
cell phones work we forget to charge
them overnight and our our bodies our
brains are are the same way same way an
athlete has to recover after a workout
our brains our body need that recovery
time to heal and rest to function I
mentioned the seven to eight hours but
it can differ from person to person how
much you really need is that true
absolutely as we age our our need for
Sleep changes young infants that are
growing need about 16 to 18 hours
adolescence it's more like seven to nine
hours and then adults should get into
the range of seven to eight after age 60
our sleep patterns can even become come
very light and sporadic which is another
reason why in our elderly patients we
always screen for Sleep disturbances I
am guilty of something that I think a
lot of people do and it's getting
through a week and maybe getting minimal
sleep and saying I'll catch up on sleep
over the weekend is that even a thing I
hate to burst your bubble with that is a
myth yeah I I equate that to putting gas
in your car you can fill your gas tank
you can keep pumping yeah but your your
car is not going to get any extra
benefit out of that so nope can't can't
store sleep and can't use that as a way
to stay up later so finding the a
routine the same bedtime the same wake
time is important absolutely hard to do
sometimes it's a wake sleep cycle our
brains actually have six different areas
that control hormones that control
waking up falling asleep and all our
different levels of sleep so it's
controlling those cycles and patterns
not just flipping the light switch so
what can people do then to make sure or
at least try try to get a better night's
sleep they're little tips well we're all
creatures of habits unfortunately of
course bad habits are much easier than
good habits exercise is a great way to
help those hormones and to train that
brain also setting a regular bedtime and
a regular wake-up time very important
cutting out stimulants late in our day
especially caffeine nicotine there are
no no shortcuts for a good night's sleep
so at what point do you see a doctor if
you think you're not getting a proper
amount of sleep for whatever reason yeah
absolutely most Sleep Experts recommend
trying these sleep hygiene techniques we
were talking about for at least a couple
weeks to see if it makes an improvement
if it doesn't in that time or certainly
if you feel like your sleep is affecting
your daily activities see your health
professional we can help you determine
if there may be other medical causes
that may be causing some of the troubles
Dr Knutson thanks so much for being here
absolutely appreciate it thank you to
Intermountain Health for sponsoring this
segment if you want more information you
can always go to Intermountain nv.org